donc voilà je vais quand même envie de
profiter qu'on passe à la télé ce soir
pour m'adresser directement au brésil et
leur proposer une solution pour sauver
l'amazonie depuis des mois c'est
l'hécatombe d'amazonie part en fumée
à chaque minute à chaque seconde des
milliers d'arbres sont incendiés
tout ça pour qu'il y ait plus de place
au brésil pour élever des vaches mais en
détruisant cette forêt c'est la planète
qu'ils vont tuer
o la belgique veut faire un geste
cependant pour sauver la planète c'est
trop important pour nos vies ne
brûlaient plus l'amazonie
et après
les la wallonie rien d'important allez-y
pour la planète ya pas de souci le monde
n'a pas besoin baraki
[Musique]
vous pouvez tout cramé ça fait des
années que c'est le foutoir puis
commencer par le bo et isla pétron - ces
connards
pour l'agriculture ça tombe bien la
wallonie est un modèle ici des vaches on
en a plein au h&m de marcinelle
c'est pas très grand ce sera rapide le
wallon s'enflamme facilement surtout à
liège ça prendra vite du tout l'alcool
qu'ils ont dans le sang
puis avance leur tranche rapport le dodo
ça laisse des séquelles pas étonnant que
le tpo soeur les ai mis dans des sacs
poubelle
crâne et où y'a rien
v la wallonie c'est pas la lui
même en
en la revendant sur ebay stéphane moreau
sera pas y tue
car si y'a qu'une seule chose c'est elle
qui compte plus de trop au final
les caisses des intercommunales c'est la
e411 bordel
elle
[Musique]
il ya des pédophiles vous verrez mais
les juges aient pas s'il vous plaît ils
n'ont pas eu le choix quand on voit la
gueule des meufs à charleroi
[Musique]
pour les terroristes et la même ici il
faut les comprendre en fait quand tu
passes 8 forem tu ressors tu achètes une
machette
dans la wallonie ça
tous les wallons sont sans abri
ils iront donc tous vivre en flandre je
suis sûr qu'ils seront bien accueillis
des wallons sont flexibles c'est vrai
ils peuvent déménager d'un coup
car ce sont des gens passionnés et
qu'ils n'ont pas de travail surtout
les flamands pourront l'art apprendre à
lire et en contrepartie
ils ont senio à la flandre comment s
class en tacchini
et tout le monde sera au septième ciel
la wallonie sera qu'un souvenir
et moi je pourrai enfin mentir et dire
que je viens de bruxelles
[Applaudissements]